Okay. So I'm really excited to get this session started, and thank you
guys for making the first session of what I hope to be
is an amazing annual meeting. I wanted to also shout out and thank
the Education Committee and Eddie Kukeman, who is in charge of the program,
for really letting us delve into highlighting comorbidities
and how they may be impacting our patients, and what the causes are.
So I'd like to get started really by talking about what my lab's doing,
but as a bit of background to really set the stage for the session, I
really wanted to, assuming my slides move,
really ask the question in the context of chemotherapy as well as other
comorbidities. We're going to hear about radiation in a little bit.
What is it we all think about when we think about patients that are exposed to
chemotherapy? And I think this is probably what most people think about.
Possibly because it's visceral, it's in your face. We see it.
It's on TV. Unfortunately, for our patients, it's but the tip of the
iceberg. Unfortunately, when we look at patients that are being treated
by a variety of modalities, this certainly isn't limited to chemotherapy.
It's going to be affected by the age of the patients for sure, the chemos they're
on, the doses they're on, the durations.
Any one of these panoplies of effects can hit them, and the degree to it, of
course, is affected by all of those different aspects I've already mentioned.
And so the question is: how do we continue to increase
lifespan for these patients, but also try to buy quality of life?
And I think that's what this session is really about, is to think about what are
the mechanisms driving any one of these, as well as others that aren't even
mentioned here. And what is it we might all be able to do about it as we try to
understand the mechanisms behind it.
So what I wanted to do in my talk is focus on neuropathy.
This is
something that affects a very large percent of patients that are treated with
chemotherapy, depending on, again, the dose, the age, the
chemo itself. This can affect upwards of 70% of patients, and this
is this classic stinging pains in the peripheral, in
the fingertips and the toes or numbness.
And unfortunately for patients, even if they beat their cancer, a large
proportion of these patients, upwards of 30% of them, can go on
for lifetimes to experience neuropathy.
So this really affects quality of life, and actually, there are cases where
patients will dose deescalate, which affects overall survival due to
the extent to which these different symptoms are going to affect them,
neuropathy being but one of them. And so we wanted to start thinking
about this in the context of what the lab works in.
And we really started to look at this in the context of what is
it that's driving senescence, and-- excuse me, driving
neuropathy. And one of the things that my lab has been focused on for quite
some time is the role that senescent cells play in
affecting neighboring cells. And chemotherapy, I have to
tell you, is probably the best way to induce senescence.
It's probably the first thing I give anyone who joins my lab because it always
works, and then all the failures that come later, they can deal with, right?
Throw chemo on cells, they senesce.
They'll take on a variety of different changes, morphological changes.
We call it a flattened egg morphology if we're talking in vitro.
They can become positive for senescence-associated beta-galactosidase, which is
this blue stain. But I think more pertinent to the talk today is they
also express a large cadre of factors that can
affect many different aspects of biology.
Large numbers of inflammatory cytokines can modulate the immune response,
both locally and systemically, ECM remodeling proteins
that can change the structure of any tissue, again, at least
locally, as well as growth factors that can affect both wound healing
as well as the growth of tumor cells.
And what was interesting to us when we were thinking about this is some of these
SAS factors or senescence-associated secretory phenotype factors
have been implicated in neuropathy in a variety of
different models. And so the question we wanted to ask is: is it
possible that senescence contributes in any demonstrable way to
neuropathy? And if so, could we understand what the cells
were and the mechanism by which they were driving this?
And so we first had to set up the models, and I just wanted to take a second to
tell you how we look at this. So if we think about the mouse paw, we
use the mouse as a model. The little bumps on the bottom of its paw are
similar, if you will, for neuronal innervation to our fingertips, if
you will. And so what we see is sensory neurons will innervate
into the dermis of those animals in the epidermis.
And of course, this is how they're actually going to feel.
One can measure this by staining with a neuronal marker,
PGP 9.5. And then one just measures how far, as I just said,
these innervate into the epidermis.
This basically looks something like this when we measure it.
If we put an animal, in this case, on paclitaxel or PTX for most of this talk.
Basically, we can see this innervation in a normal mouse, and when we quantify it,
we see a classic denervation when these animals are on.
This is exactly what also happens to patients who go on to develop
CIPN. And then this actually has a,
beyond the morphologic changes I'm showing you here, can have a behavioral change
in the mice. And we like to use a-- well, one can use a variety of different
assays. We like to use what we lovingly refer to as the poky test or the
Von Frey. And what one does in this particular setting is you put a filament, and
you just push and find out how much pressure do you need to apply to the bottom of
the planar surface of the mouse's paw to actually elicit a response,
i.e., when do they start feeling that push.
And basically, that denervation that I showed you in the slide
before translates here then, in this case, to it takes more
pressure to push. These mice are experiencing neurologic symptom, in this case, a
numbness. It basically needs more pressure for them to actually feel what's
actually happening. And so we wanted to really ask the question
then, given the fact that many of the SAS factors that we have looked
at in other aspects of biology have been implicated in CIPN,
was it possible that senescence was contributing to this phenotype in some
way?And so when we start thinking about the nervous system and
neurons themselves, there are many different places we may need to pay attention.
In the dorsal root ganglia, this is where the cell bodies find themselves, then
they obviously run along the nerve, and then to the eventual
axons that innervate into the periphery.
In the interest of time, I'm not going to show you all the negative data.
I'm just going to summarize by saying despite our best efforts, we were unable to
find any evidence of senescence in the dorsal root ganglia, and
furthermore, along the entire sural and sciatic nerve, there was no evidence of
senescent cells. And so we wanted to go on and focus then on the
periphery. And when we started to first just look, we found that there
was a significant increase in p16 mRNA expression
in animals that were treated with paclitaxel, and this was also true at the
protein level. So why focus on p16?
Well, p16 by itself is not a senescent marker.
It is a marker that often tells us we may have senescent cells.
In addition to that, we have a number of tools in which we can use to manipulate
p16-positive cells, senescent cells in this case.
And so we wanted to ask the question then, given this increase in p16
in the periphery specifically, are these cells contributing to the
CIPN or the neuropathy that these animals were experiencing?
And as I just said, we have a number of tools that allow us to do this.
And one of our favorite tools that we start with when we're thinking about a
potential role for senescence is a mouse model that Darren Baker created many
years ago when he was in Jan Van Deursen's lab.
And just briefly, the way this particular model works is there's a minimal
p16 promoter, hence our fixation with p16, that can
drive an inducible suicide gene. And so what this allows
us to do is basically kill senescent cells in a relatively
specific manner. And so we used this animal and first
went back and looked again in those planar surfaces in the periphery for a
marker of senescence beyond p16, in this case, senescence-associated
beta-galactosidase. And I hope what you can appreciate is we see significant
increases in the periphery of animals treated with paclitaxel.
And when we use that and activate the inducible suicide gene by applying
AP, which is the drug that dimerizes the suicide gene, we
significantly eliminate, again, those
SA-beta-gal positive cells in the periphery.
And so we had two different markers to argue that senescence was there and that
this mouse model might actually be affecting the presence of these cells.
In addition, perhaps not surprising then, if we also go back in now and look in the
periphery of animals in which we've induced the suicide gene for the
p16 protein, as I showed you with the
SA-beta-gal, the increase in the p16 positive there with the blue
bar is significantly reduced when we activate the suicide gene.
So we can certainly modulate the presence and absence of these cells within the
periphery. And so what happens then to the symptoms of
neuropathy? When we first look at innervation into these animals,
again, I hope what you can appreciate is upon paclitaxel, we see significant
denervation in these animals, which is completely obliterated when we kill
senescent cells in the periphery.
And importantly, this translates to a behavioral effect.
That numbness that these animals were experiencing there with the PTX in the blue
bar is completely abrogated, again, when we eliminate
senescent cells from the periphery of these animals.
So we can prevent it. Of course, one of the questions is,
is the presence of senescent cells also maintaining this phenotype?
Can we actually rescue the phenotype?
And so to do that, what we decided to do was, again, the same experiment we had
done in the past, but this time, instead of eliminating senescence
throughout the course of the paclitaxel treatment, instead what we did
was to let these animals develop symptoms of CIPN
and then go in, eliminate the senescent cells, and ask what actually
happens. Here again, I'm showing innervation.
As expected, if we wait 10 days in this case, these animals
have evidence of axonal denervation.
And when we kill senescent cells after that, we actually get a reinnervation
of the epidermis within these animals.
And importantly for the animals, again, I think at the end of the day,
it really is, what is the behavioral effect on these
animals? And so here what I'm showing you is, we have three lines here
now. So again, in the blue there with paclitaxel, these animals have developed
numbness. And then if we don't treat them, we just leave them for another
month, what you'll notice is their paw threshold there actually drops below
the controls. This is actually an indication of pain.
So if we leave these animals untreated for over a month, they move
from numbness to pain, which can also happen with patients.
Importantly, if at the time they've developed numbness, we now start
to eliminate the senescent cells, this pain is
completely reversed, and these animals go back to baseline.
So they've reinnervated into the periphery, but they've also
eliminated the behavioral effect that's ahead of them.
So that's a genetic approach. Can we
confirm this with a pharmacologic approach?
And so to do this, we like to use a drug class called senolytics.
This is a class of drugs that can kill senescent cells.
How, in fact, these drugs particularly work is still an area of debate within the
field. But using a number of controls, usually
p16-positive, SA-beta-gal cells really are the only cells that we see
that are demonstrably eliminated when we use, in this case, dasatinib
and quercetin as a mixed combination.
I'm showing you the data in a little bit different way here, but basically, again,
this was where we let the animals, after treatment, develop
pain. So what you can see with that paw threshold in the blue and the red, these
are animals treated with paclitaxel.
Their paw thresholds have dropped lower than their baselines.
In other words, they've gone on to develop pain.
Once they've developed the pain, if we now start to treat them with our
senolytics, this is the red
line if you look at it, we actually recover these animals back to wild type,
arguing that, again, both with a pharmacologic approach as well as the genetic
approach, by eliminating senescent cells in the periphery, we can actually
reverse the symptoms of CIPN.So I told you
that the only evidence of increases in p16 that we could find were in
fact in the periphery. And so the question is, what were the cells that are
driving this and how are they driving this?
What do you do when you have no idea? Hope single cell will lead the way.
And so we decided to run some single cell on the planar surfaces of those
animals. And while it's a small subset of fibroblasts, the
only p16 that we could identify within that single cell data set was
in fact a small subset of fibroblasts by at least GSO
scores, they show an increase in overall senescent signature.
So we went in,
I have a thing in my lab, I don't believe RNA without protein.
So if we went in and then stained the planar surfaces of these animals
for PDGF-R alpha, which is a marker of fibroblasts, not by itself
the only marker, and p16, I hope what you can appreciate with the
connotation there over to the right, is that we see an increase in p16
positive, that should be on the label, I apologize, a PDGF-R positive
cells, and those are eliminated when we treat the animals with AP.
Again, this is our way to genetically eliminate p16 positive
senescent cells.
This isn't just in mice. If we take samples, and please
bear with me, we've got three, so anybody who's got samples, we'd like to increase
this number, but when we look at the skin samples of patients with
CIPN, we actually see significant increases in overall
mRNA in those patients relative to age-matched unaffected
individuals. And when we go back and stain, as I said, bear with me,
there's only three patients there, we actually do see evidence of
senescent fibroblasts within the skin of these patients.
So we think that these cells may be actually very important also in
patients.
And so how do we prove those cells are the pointy end of the stick?
To do this, we took a step back. We actually re-engineered that Inc- 攻
击 mouse Darren Baker made many years ago and just simply introduced a
lox stop lox cassette into that, so we could now mate this
to our favorite Cre lines and really now focus our
killing, if you will, or the induction of our suicide gene in, in this case,
PDGF-R alpha positive fibroblasts.
And in doing that, what we found, again perhaps not surprising, is if
we take animals and we measure the innervation, we see that reduction with
paclitaxel. However, when we eliminate the senescent cells, not
only do we reinnervate or stop the denervation, I should say, I
apologize for that, we actually are able again to inhibit the induction
of the behavioral effect, i.e. the numbness that we
saw when we treat animals with paclitaxel, arguing then that
those senescent fibroblasts are the pointy end of the stick.
And so how are they doing that? I've mentioned now at least three times
that senescent cells secrete a large cadre of factors that are known
to impact neighboring cells in a variety of different ways.
Again, that's collectively referred to as the senescence-associated secretory
phenotype or the SASP. And what was important for us is to really
think about what it is that regulates the SASP itself.
And so over a decade ago, I had a very talented graduate student that was
interested in understanding the regulation of the SASP as a whole.
And what she was able to show many years ago is that the
SASP really is subject to p38
modulation. And so the p38 kinase acting through its downstream
kinase, MK2, is able to phosphorylate
HSP27 and thereby stabilize messenger RNA
specifically of the SASP. And so the question that Taylor in the
lab wanted to ask is, we know that it's senescent fibroblasts that
are playing an important role in CIPN.
Are they mediating that through secreted factors, specifically the SASP, that are
modulated by the MK2 kinase? And so to do that,
we have a floxed allele of the MK2 kinase.
We went and mated that mouse now again to that PDGF-alpha Cre,
allowing us to exclusively eliminate MK2 from that
population. I'm not going to show you the innervation data in the interest of
time, just the behavioral data, but I hope what you can appreciate is,
again, that increase in the paw threshold, i.e.
the numbness that animals that were treated with paclitaxel exhibit, that's
completely eliminated when we take MK2 now out
exclusively and only in the PGF positive cells,
arguing that MK2 activation in those senescent fibroblasts
is key to the CIPN. And I'm not showing you the data, but
we can show you that the senescent cells are still retained in the tissue here.
They just no longer are expressing the SASP.
So can we actually use this in
patients one day, this being inhibition of MK2?
We actually have a trial right now in the metastatic breast cancer setting using an
MK2 inhibitor. We're still in dose escalation, so this isn't for
CIPN, but we thought, if this drug actually
does well and we can inhibit MK2 with a drug, if
that could affect CIPN, maybe this is something we could potentially offer to
patients in the future. So to do this, we took our animals again, treated
them with paclitaxel, and now used an orally available MK2 inhibitor that,
as I just mentioned, we have in a clinical trial.
And here I hope you can appreciate again that that denervation we see when animals
are treated with paclitaxel, when they're on the orally available MK2
inhibitor, we completely inhibit the ability--
I should say, the denervation. So we're not seeing denervation.
And of course, importantly, that numbness that we see upon treatment is
again inhibited on this drug. And so we think that this is very promising as a
potential to move forward in a clinical trial.
So what I've tried to show you today, and I think the data are pretty strong,
paclitaxel activates senescence in the periphery,
specifically fibroblasts. I think one of the $100 million questions that I don't
have an answer for is why is this so specific to fibroblasts?
I think it's biologically very interesting, but we don't really have an answer for
you on that one today. But through then the secreted SASP that is
dependent on the MK2 kinase, that SASP is
acting on the-On the axons,
and we're actually seeing a de-innervation, which translates again
into numbness, let it go long enough, pain Using the MK2
inhibitor or a senolytic to get rid of the senescent cells, we can
completely, obviously, eliminate the SASP and thereby protect the
neurons. And so with that, I want to actually finish with the most important lab,
or this is my lab. They're a lot of fun. That was a lot of Sheilas for one day.
That was Halloween last year. But they do all the work, and I importantly want to
point out the person who did all of this work.
This is Taylor Malatosi right here at the bottom.
I guess that's the blue Sheila. And with that, I would be happy to take any
questions.
And please use the microphones.
Stunned silence. Okay with... Oh.
Well.
Go ahead.
Thank you for that amazing talk. I was wondering if this applies also
to orustatins, which are the common payload for
ADCs as well. They also induce peripheral neuropathy.
Do you think they act by a similar mechanism?
Can you repeat that? I'm sorry. I didn't get the question.
Do you think a similar mechanism could be involved in the peripheral neuropathy
that is caused by orustatins?
Are you getting a reverb? There's a really terrible reverb.
I'm
wondering if this mechanism is also involved in
orustatins, which are the payloads for
ADCs. Does
it induce peripheral neuropathy?
So if you guys didn't get the question, sorry.
She's wondering if this same mechanism was in place for payloads that deliver
ADCs. We have not tested that. We've only tested the
paclitaxel that I've showed you in cisplatin.
In cisplatin, we see the same effect, but we've only looked at the chemotherapy.
Any other questions?
Oh, go ahead.
Since you've already kind of answered it, I was wondering if you looked at
vincristine or anything with that.
So he-
Well, no.
Yeah. So he asked if we've looked at vincristine.
We have not looked at vincristine, but we have looked at cisplatin at this point.
Yeah.
Just my question is, were you using any traditional senolytic like
navitoclax? Did you have like cancer
models or cancer that you
tried to-
Yeah.
So the question was, have we used other classic senolytics like navitoclax, and
have we done this in the context of a tumor-bearing animal to ask?
And the answer is yes, and yes. So, in the interest of time, I
didn't show you the tumor-bearing, but we work with breast cancer in my lab, so
we've only tested it with breast cancer models.
If we give the animals either a metastatic disease or we give them
primary, treat them with paclitaxel, we do see the reduction in
tumor as we would hope,
and then we see the same effects. We have also tested-- And so we've
used DQ in that setting, and we see the same effect.
We've used the MK2 inhibitor, we see the same effect.
We've not used the navitoclax with the tumors, but we have used it in the
tumor-free, and it also works.
Yeah, I had a question. In your experience, what types of
chemotherapy are the most potent inducers of CIPN?
Yeah. So paclitaxel is pretty good at it.
Vincristine is particularly good at it. You see it with cisplatin.
And actually, bortezomib, which is not a classic chemo, is
also very good at it. We have not tested bortezomib.
Yeah.
Are patients that have CIPN more
likely to relapse ?
Are they more likely to relapse?
Somebody who knows more than me. No.
I was going to say, I don't have an answer to that, but Nina knows. No.
Yes.
All right. Thank you very much. I think we're going to move on to the next talk.
So now it's time to learn about how radiation can be not good for you.
All right. So I'm hoping if they open these doors, the echo will
tone down a little bit.
So anyway, we're going to switch to radiation,
and we're going to switch to the brain, the CNS, not the periphery,
but a lot of what you just heard is also caused by radiation.
So for those of you who don't know me, I'm Dr. Limoli.
I'm up at UCI, just 60 miles north.
I spent my entire career studying what radiation does to the brain.
I've spent 30 years up with NASA funding, advising NASA of
what happened to the brains of astronauts due to space radiation,
and I'm going to tell you now what happens to people,
largely through my studies with rodents, what happens to the
irradiated brain, and what are some of the comorbidities associated with that.
And so
I'm going to briefly go over some of the
time course and the types of radiation injury in the brain.
Talk a little bit of some structure function relationships that
impact cognition,
and I'm not going to leave you with a dire note.
I've got a couple of things that give us hope for the future, and I'm going
to finish this talk with a new type of radiation delivery that
promises to revolutionize the way we treat all cancer patients in the
future.
But before we get into that,
let's talk about what we do do well.
And so,
when I was a young kid, no one lived 20 years with their cancer.
There weren't a lot of long-term survivors.
That's gone up dramatically, and so now the NIH has
recognized that this is a chronic disease, and we need to
treat the complications that arise from cancer therapy.
And so you can see that we have well over 25 million cancer
survivors in the US.Not all of these are going to be the
focus of my talk but these bring into, "Look,
damn, I got cancer." You survive cancer and now you have
these complications. So I've spent my career, among many of my
colleagues, trying to figure out how to improve what Dr.
Stewart just talked about CIPN, but different
indication for me, how we can minimize these complications and
improve the quality of life of cancer survivors.
So as I said,
my expertise is looking at what radiation does to the brain
and
who gets radiation to the brain. No normal
person's going to volunteer to get irradiated in the brain, but for
those people that are unfortunate enough to get afflicted with brain tumors,
this is one of the primary treatment modalities we use to forestall the
growth of both primary and metastatic progression of CNS malignancies.
We can do whole brain. We're moving towards more partial
brain. We're moving towards more stereotactic approaches to treat both
brain mets in primary low-grade gliomas.
And many of these people do survive, not necessarily the
GBM patients, but low-grade glioma patients survive.
And for the kids, the primary brain cancer is medulloblastoma,
and there's some very rare types that are very lethal, but we're pretty good at
treating that. We get about 80% survival.
But these kids all go on to exhibit long-term
difficulties in learning, accommodations for school,
and have an increased risk of stroke, among many other problems.
And so well over half of the people that we try to get
rid of the tumors in the brain with radiation go on to suffer
from what we call these cognitive deficits.
And so
it's important to understand why these occur, and if we
don't understand why this happens, we really can't come up with interventions to
forestall it.
So when you get irradiated, you don't get up off the
table and suffer cognitive impairments.
What happens early in the brain
transitions to late effects, and for 30 years, this
has confounded the entire field of CNS radio biology,
linking what happens during the early time
course here, where we've got cell loss, some endothelial apoptosis,
to some of the intermediate effects, the early delayed effects, where you start
getting some demyelination. You have some reactive
cascades involving ROS and inflammation.
And then you get to the late functional outcomes where you have impaired cognition.
What happens in between is very difficult to figure out, and
we've been wrestling with this for decades.
Nonetheless,
I focused on really functional outcomes, trying to fix the
single most important functional outcome in all cancer treatment, except for, of
course, overall survival, and that's neurocognitive
impairments. And so progressive
dimension in long-term brain tumor survivors is a problem.
As you can see from this graph, radiation and, by the way,
chemotherapy impact every facet of your cognition from fine
motor skills, and really it has a big impact on
people like us who rely on our executive function and to multitask
and problem solve. And these are the types of things that are the
first to go when you're treated with chemo or radiotherapy.
And so
let me tell you a little bit about radiation before I get into this.
radiation's a modern miracle of medicine.
It's painless, it's non-invasive, and if it's used properly,
it's super useful. And this is underappreciated in the cancer
community. And a lot of what I'm going to tell you could not be
possible without research support for animals, because, as I said
before, no
normal healthy person's going to get irradiated, and the data that I
show you, there's nothing that indicates that the response of a neuron in a
rodent brain is any different than what you see in a human.
And so what are the common mechanisms my colleagues
and I have found over the years? This is kind of a complicated
slide, but one of the underlying commonalities, and this is true
across all tissues, but particularly important in the brain, is this elevated
inflammation. We get lots of reactive microglia after
irradiation, which are the innate macrophages of the brain.
We have inflammation, and we have a lot of cytokine
signaling. We have loss of neurogenesis, hippocampal
atrophy. We have reductions in hippocampal volume, right?
And after brain tumor treatment, you get some
white matter radionecrosis, but the neurocognitive
decrements are locked in well before at much lower doses.
We also have a reorganization of neurotransmitter networks, and I
can say this pretty confidently, the irradiated brain is never
normal again. And so
there's a lot of disruptions to the integrity of the irradiated brain, and I'm
going to show you some evidence for that.
And so cranial radiation induces lots of neuronal and
synaptic damage and glial activation.
I'm just going to put up a few references from our team, and
you can look all these up. I don't want to get into all the details.
We've got well over 40 publications in this field.
But I'd like to hit a couple of highlights that for those of you not familiar with
this field,
we used a relatively simple model
10, 12 years ago that had inherently fluorescent neurons, and
believe it or not, no one in the field had really looked at what happens to
mature neural populations when you irradiate them until
Dr. Parihar did his postdoc in my lab.
And what we find is if we go from 0, 10 in
1 centigray across the top, the structure of these dendrites is
severely compromised. And it doesn't take a neuroscientist
to figure out that going from 0 to 1 gray, there's much less complexity in
the dendritic tree. The arborization's less complex.
Now, if we zoom in-And we look at some of these red structures here on
the right. These are the dendritic spines that are
the structural correlates of learning and memory.
As you can see, these are different radiation types we've used over the years,
we've protons, charged particles, this is true with photons as
well. We've stripped the spines off these dendrites.
And we
can tell what types of spines are impacted.
And what we see is the immature filopodia and long spines are the
ones that are impacted, not the mature spines.
So what's that tell you about the mechanism?
It tells you that you're impacting your capability to learn.
You're not going to lose your long-term memories, and that's exactly what we see in
our cognitive testing in the animals.
Radiation doesn't make you forget your parents, but it impacts your
ability to learn new tricks. And so
these types of studies led to a lot of
conclusions, and I'm summarizing a lot of work here.
The deficits caused in the irradiated brain are permanent.
Okay? They don't resolve.
Both low doses and low dose rates cause dramatic changes in the brain.
Doses that are much less than prescribed clinical doses for glioma.
Deficits occur in the relative absence of cell loss.
So the whole brain is the target. Okay?
This is not radiolytic targets in the brain.
It's a super complicated structure.
For functional CNS outcomes, the dose, the dose rate,
and RBE models don't impact functional outcomes.
I know this may be contrary to what a lot of the clinicians think, but trust
me on this one. So
given this kind of dire backdrop, what might we be able to do to
alleviate some of these adverse consequences of radiation exposure in the
brain? And now I transition to two people in my lab.
Professor Acharya has really laid the backdrop for a lot of these studies in an
early PNAS paper. Basically, what we have is a
relatively simplified scheme where we'll take a host, and it could
be rats, in this case, nude rats, who are going to put human stem cells in
them, or mice. We grow up stem cells, we irradiate
the animals, and we inject them initially.
We either use stem cells or extracellular vesicles derived from these
stem cells. We put them into the hippocampus, or we can
introduce them systemically through retro-orbital injection.
Then we kind of wash our hands of the situation and see what happens.
And so what we found is that in order to do these types of
tests, we better be able to do one thing well, and that's be able to
assay or
evaluate cognitive performance.
So we've adapted a lot of spatial
orientation tasks involving either a
novel object coming in or a novel location involved.
And so these spontaneous exploration tasks
can inform me to some extent. We've also used
fear extinction as a task that doesn't involve locomotion.
We've adapted certain puzzle box tests to increase the
level of rigor, so it asks the animals to do problem-solving.
And there's other tests for anxiety and things like this.
And so we've co-opted a lot of the tests that neuroscientists have
developed over years to ask the question of whether
the deficits that radiation cause can be
reversed. And much to our joy, what we can see
is, so the higher on the y-axis, the smarter these animals are.
Here's our controls. Here's a reduction in their ability to
discriminate novelty. But when we transplant stem cells two days
to a month later, we completely resolve that deficit.
And on a fear conditioning task, if you focus right here in the middle, here's
our control.
The animals don't freeze as much after radiation.
This is a sign of becoming dumber. This is a predation
response, to freeze. The animals that actually get the transplants recover
that freeze response. So this is important because this doesn't involve
locomotion. And we can do the same thing with extracellular
vesicles. So we can inject these systemically.
There's no need for immune suppression.
And all of these tasks here show more or less the same thing.
Going from control to the stem cell-injected, they do much better than
the graphs in the middle where these animals show impairments, and we get the
same result here in fear conditioning.
So
we can look at these. This is a Goldji stained rat brain.
And again, you can see the complexity, much like I showed you on the green
neurons from the mice. So now these are rats.
Look at the complexity of the dendritic tree.
Look what happens after you irradiate, and look what happens after you put the stem
cells in.
So this radiation is really wiping out the structure in the brain of these
animals. And in fact, the same things happened if we use
cyclophosphamide. So radiation and chemotherapy
phenocopy many of the types of adverse complications in the
brain. So here's control
cyclophosphamide-treated, and now we come in with our stem cells, and what
you can see here is we're looking at the spines.
So these are the little red structures I showed before.
Cyclophosphamide strips these spines right off, and we would come in with the stem
cells. We can completely restore these.
And we can measure all these morphometric parameters.
But suffice to say, we can preserve the morphometric
complexity of these neurons with stem cell or extracellular vesicle
transplantation. And what we've also been able to do is we can
also significantly attenuate neuroinflammation.
So on these graphs here, the irradiated animals are in red in the
middle, and you can see here, this is just one measure.
This is an ED1 positive microglia across various
regions of the brain. And compared to controls, you can see that
this elevated
level of inflammation is quite high.
But miraculously, whether you look in the hippocampus, the amygdala,
or various layers of the cortex, the presence of these extracellular
vesicles knocks this inflammation back down almost to below control
levels. So if you can preserve the integrity of
neuronsIf you can reduce the inflammation, you're going to
do a world of good for your patients.
And to summarize a lot of what we've found, and again, we've had numerous
publications on this
We know that with a single systemic injection, we can improve not only
CNS, but pulmonary and cardiac toxicity.
One injection after radiotherapy.
The mechanism of action of this is an attenuation of
inflammation, the preservation of the structure of neurons,
immediate early gene activation such as Arc, activity
regulated cytoskeletal protein, and c-Fos.
And we've also done microRNA cargo analysis and, for example,
miR-124, if we inject it in on the adenovirus, can
completely resolve radiation-induced cognitive deficits.
So we're trying to move a lot of this into trials.
We have a GMP facility that can grow exosomes and stem
cells now. It was started last year at UCI.
But let me give you a little more hope now for those people that are cranially
irradiated or might suffer from cancer anywhere.
And I'd like to introduce you to
a promising intervention that's on the horizon that's being developed
across every radiation oncology center in the world.
And this has to do-- It was started by this blue box, which is a
linac, that delivers radiation
very quickly. So normally when you go to the clinic, you get a
gray, which is a joule per kilogram, delivered over the
course of minutes. Now we can deliver hundreds of gray in
a second. And this was originally developed to solve this problem
here, where when you were irradiated normally,
your irradiation time is on the scale of physiologic motion.
And
if your tumor comes in and out of the target, that's not good.
So now when we deliver this radiation super quick, we've solved the organ
motion problem that the NIH has spent millions of dollars trying to
solve. So
what is this? This is called flash radiotherapy,
which was started in 2014 by some clever scientists
in Switzerland and France. But what we have here
is a timescale of radiation events that transcends
the age of the universe. So what happens over this
timescale? So
we're impinging on things here. So an attosecond is to a
second, what a second is to the age of the universe.
And so we're impacting things in that pico to the
microsecond range that then have implications out to late
effects for all functional outcomes across all normal tissues.
And this is what we call the flash effect, and we've observed this
with X-rays, low and high energy electrons, protons,
and charged particles such as carbon.
So it's modality agnostic. And the beauty of this
is, is over the last 10 years, there have been
about 400 to 500 publications ranging from physics
to biology, chemistry, and even we've started some clinical trials
in this country with protons. And what the beauty of this is, and here's a
few reviews for those of you that might want to dig into this a bit deeper.
Here's tumor control. So the holy grail of any cancer treatment
is to increase the therapeutic index.
So you have to have some differential effect between a cancer and a normal
tissue. And what we have here is if the tumor control is the
same, which is the case for flash radiotherapy, and I'll get into that
next slide. Normally, our normal tissue control
probability is here with conventional.
So conventional is the way we treat cancer now in the clinic.
But if we use flash, we drive this to the right, we
expand the therapeutic index, and therefore we
can accomplish in a microsecond what takes drug
companies 10 to 15 years to get FDA approval on to treat just one
cancer, and we can do this differentially across every normal tissue
site that might be burdened with cancer.
So
what is the
basis of what I'm saying? So we have shown
with very high energy electrons, protons, lower
energy electrons, X-rays, and carbon ions, using all of
these normal tissue sites in animal models ranging from
zebrafish to rodents to mini pigs, cats, and
dogs, that in the brain, in the lung, in the skin,
in the gut, bone, and the muscle, every normal tissue
shows a reduction, a significant reduction, up to dose
modifying factors of up to 1.4 in normal tissue toxicity.
The beauty of the technique is every tumor we've studied to
date is dose rate independent. That means the tumors are not
spared. So this is unbelievable, and
this is why all the clinicians are super excited about this, and this is what
I think the future of radiotherapy is going to be.
And so
I can answer any questions you might have on it.
I wrote this review looking into the plausible and implausible
mechanisms, and where the field stands right now is that
there's probably very unique protein targets that
are in normal tissue that last for the entire lifespan.
They're called long-lived proteins.
These proteins dictate how long you live.
Yes, there's proteins that last your entire life.
These proteins are not in tumors. And we think a lot of these
proteins are differentially sensitive to dose rate delivered
in the clinic. There's also a role
for mitochondrial metabolism and differential lipid
peroxidation between low and high dose rates.
So if you might ask me, when the heck are we going to get this in the clinic?
Right now, we're trying to develop-- We have large
consortias working on this. I'm deeply involved with getting the machines able
to deliver this. But
is the flash effect robust and reproducible?
Absolutely.Question two, can flash effect be
maintained with what we do in the clinic? In other words, fractionation?
Yes. Question three, can it be maintained in
combined modality? Most likely, yes.
There's a few tricks we still have to solve there.
Can we deliver it conformally? So conformally means if I see
the tumor and shape the beam, I hit what I want to hit and thereby you
reduce normal tissue complications.
We're not quite there yet. But is it ready with the available
preclinical data for more advanced trials? Absolutely.
And so,
there have been a couple of recent calls from the NIH, among others,
ARPA-H. We're finally getting the infusion of
money into radiotherapy that we've been competing with the big drug
companies. We're trying to come up with an overall solution
for curing cancer with a single dose, and the
overall budget that we've been given from this ARPA foundation is close to
$150 million,
and we're hoping that we have a big consortium across the whole country.
That's a small price to pay for any advancement that could potentially
treat any cancer in the body. So
I hope I've perked your interest in this.
I hope I've let you know that even though radiation induced cognitive
dysfunction is a bummer, we're working on trying to fix it.
And
here's part of my A team. I've been lucky to have a bit of funding in
my time, and I'll be happy to answer questions.
So if there are questions, please come to the microphone.
I'll just ask a question because obviously I can't think beyond senescence.
If radiation is very good at inducing senescence, what about flash?
Does it also induce senescence?
Reduces it. Well, yes, there's a level of it, but much less than
conventional.
Oh, come on, you guys aren't going to buy all that that I said without questioning
it, are you?
Come on up.
People in the back need to come up. That way, we don't have to use these
microphones and hear the echo.
Hey, Charlie, good to see you. Shout out from Doug Spitz, too.
How you doing?
How you doing? Is there a difference in the extent or the
milieu of ROS generated between flash and conventional
radiotherapy?
You know what? I'm having a super hard time hearing you with this echo.
Can you just come up?
Just yell it.
Yeah.
Yeah. And he'll repeat the question.
Is there a difference in the extent or the milieu of
ROS generated between conventional RT and flash
RT?
So the question was, does flash and conventional
radiotherapy differentially impact the production of reactive
oxygen species? So we have pretty good evidence that reactive oxygen
species production is lowered
after flash, but that's not the driving mechanism of flash
across all tissues.
Hello, sir. Hope you hear me fine.
Is that okay?
Do you hear me?
I can hear you, yes.
Okay. So great talk. It's pretty nice to see about
radiation. How
much is this better than grid radiation,
which also shows
a lot less effects on healthy tissue and also shows great,
better behavior analysis?
Are you asking me
how much better this is?
Yeah. Flash and grid radiation. What's the major difference?
Okay. So
if you look at late responding tissues, and those are
the tissues that take a long time to manifest functional decrement, such as
the lung and the brain, we routinely observe dose modifying
factors of 1.4. That means that if I'm
a,
for example, radiotherapist, neurosurgeon that typically gives 60
gray to try to treat a GBM, now I can
deliver 90 gray and keep at least the normal tissue
complications the same and more aggressively pursue curative
intent. If we're talking about an earlier responding
tissue that responds more acutely like the intestines,
we'll observe dose modifying factors of 1.1 to 1.2.
So
a lot is a relative term, but it's better than what we do
now. Now look, I'm not going to sit here and tell you this is the cure to
cancer, but I'm going to tell you, compared to what we do now,
it offers patients a lot more hope for every cancer
they have than what we're currently doing.
So I think it's certainly something worthy of pursuit.
In the back?
Really good talk. I had a quick question about the
cognitive improvement induced by stem cells.
How long does it typically last? Have you guys looked?
How long did the what last?
The cognitive improvement induced by the stem cells.
Cognitive improvement.
So,
right. So the impairments we see
last for the lifetime of our experiment.
The improvements are locked in until we sacrifice the animals.
So remember,
unfortunately for us to do some of those pretty pictures of the neurons and
look at what cell types were affected, we have to put the little
creatures to sleep.
So we're doing our cognitive impairment obviously before we do that.
So a lot of our studies looking at the outcomes of
cognition last from six to nine months after the
actual time of radiation.
Thank you.
Okay.
So we started with immediate effects, things that take longer to
develop, and now we're going to finish the session talking about really
lifelong events after therapy. And so Melissa Hudson from St.
Jude.
Thank you for the opportunity to include a pediatric-focused session
in this very important outcome session.
Just acknowledging these disclosures,
and then starting with acknowledging again the dramatic improvement that we've
seen in survival over these past six decades, highlighted
from SEER data,
and this is in pediatric five-year event-free survival.
But we know that over time, in following our
long-term childhood cancer survivors, that recurrence and
progression-related mortality plateaus, whereas by
25 years, health-related mortality increases
and causes a specific burden and risk for early mortality.
The health-related mortality data is from the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort Study. The mortality data here on the last
illustration is from the Childhood Cancer Survivors Study, showing that there is
an excess mortality in Childhood Cancer Survivors Study
participants compared to that of the US population,
such that by 40 years, it has reached almost 25%
and is quite significant. And what is underpinning this mortality?
It is long-term and late onset effects of the cancer experience,
which encompass a spectrum of physical and psychosocial morbidities,
which may impact aspects of growth and development,
organ function, prospects for fertility and
reproduction, a risk not only of recurrent primary
cancer but also subsequent neoplasms, and many
aspects of psychosocial functioning.
We know that often these outcomes are related to specific
cancer treatments or specific cancers, but it's
important to remember that the general cancer experience can be quite
influential, especially in psychosocial outcomes and how that family
has adjusted and moved on from the cancer experience.
And it's also important to note that most long-term survivors do
report that some aspect of their health has been impacted by their cancer
experience.
These late effects actually contribute to a high risk of
multimorbidity and burden of chronic health conditions in our aging
survivors. This translates to excess hospitalizations and
healthcare utilization, and may result in work limitations
and challenges with insurance access, as well as financial
hardship and quality-of-life deficits.
Now, I want to use some data from the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort to illustrate what we've learned about the burden of
morbidity in our childhood cancer population that is aging.
In this first study, we looked at prevalence of long-term and late effects after
risk-based screening. At that point in the study, we
drove our screening based on specific anticipated
toxicities from specific therapies.
So if they had a risk for pulmonary toxic or
cardiotoxic outcomes, they would have that appropriate
screening. This was not standardized at this point, and we were
using the guidelines at that point of COG, Children's Oncology Group, Version
IV. And you see in the figure the proportion
that were at risk that were screened for specific outcomes,
and
this figure shows that those in red, actually the proportion that
was detected during their St. Jude Life evaluation, an
on-campus clinical screening,
noting the substantial burden of
occult and undiagnosed disease in this survivor population
with the highest yield for this screening, 20% or greater for
pulmonary function deficits, heart valve abnormalities, cognitive
deficits, dyslipidemia, and hypothalamic
pituitary disorders, as well as for a
yield at 10% to 20% at risk for hearing loss, ocular
toxicity, and neuropathy.
We also noted in looking at the cumulative prevalence of chronic health conditions
in these St. Jude LIFE participants that with increasing age, as
well as time from diagnosis,
the majority, more than 90%, would have at least one
chronic health condition, and among those,
85% were serious, disabling, or life-threatening.
Now, one would expect, based on cumulative incidence or prevalence, that
we are looking at a broad
view of outcomes of our survivors.
And in this figure, we note that the cumulative incidence, which looks at the
outcomes to a first event in a specific organ system, in this case
cardiovascular conditions in our Hodgkin lymphoma survivors, it appears
that our community controls in the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort Study approach the level of morbidity
of our survivors by the time they are 50 years of age.
But using a novel metric developed by Dr.
Nikhil Bhatta and colleagues,
we see that this cumulative burden metric, which accounts for
multiple and recurrent events within the same organ system,
there is always an excess morbidity in our survivor
population compared with the control population across the
lifespan.
And this cumulative burden morbidity
actually gives us a way that is important to look at specific organ
system toxicities over the lifespan.
So here, the figure shows cumulative burden of
individuals. We see our control
population here on the left, and then specific
diagnostic groups on the horizontal axis.
And we can see, looking at the color-coded
system effects, in some disease groups, for example,
Hodgkin lymphoma, there are conditions that increase in
prevalence over time, whereas in others, in this case, central nervous
system tumor survivors, they are relatively static over time, in this
case, neurologic conditions.
And this metric also lets us appreciate the
multimorbidity experienced by our survivors here, and estimated
by age 50, our survivors will experience an average of 17
chronic health conditions, including almost five that are graded as
severe, disabling, life-threatening, or
fatal.We note that this multimorbidity is
also associated directly with mortality, and here another St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort study looking at modifiable chronic health conditions
and their independent association with risk of late death, such that three or
more modifiable chronic health conditions
had a rate ratio of 3.6 for predicting death.
But we also noted within this study that area deprivation
in the neighborhood and the built environment also
increased the rate ratio for predicting death to
5.5 if they were in the 51st to 80th percentile for
deprivation, and almost ninefold if they were in the
81st to 100 percentile. So this really tells us that we
need to consider not only treatment, but also resources
available to those survivors and as we are preparing our
interventions to try to remediate some of this toxicity.
Now, we've had decades in pediatric cancer outcome studies in
linking specific treatment exposures to outcomes, in
this case, examples for chemotherapy.
We've understood, based on treatment fields and volumes and organs at
risk, a spectrum of effects that can occur related to
radiation therapy.
And even with surgery, we have good associations with specific procedures
that can be impactful long term to our survivors, and we're
mounting evidence about the outcomes of transplant and cell and gene
therapy with the caveat that many of these newer interventions, we
really do not know the late health outcomes, and they will require further
study for many, many decades to establish have we been able to
overcome and have a benefit that is going to exceed the
harms from these treatments.
So beyond treatments and disease, we know that there are many
other factors that contribute to specific outcomes.
So I'm going to give you some examples, considering my limited time, but I could
go into a specific lecture on each one of these.
So obviously, genetic contributions to mortality are well
established. This is another St. Jude Lifetime Cohort study in
which we did whole genome sequencing of our cohort, noting that
15% had one or more subsequent neoplasms, and among the
cohort, 6% had a pathogenic or likely pathogenic mutation,
as noted in the figure. And the mutations were associated with
increased risk of subsequent neoplasms in both irradiated
survivors with breast and sarcoma, as well as non-irradiated
survivors with any second neoplasm, breast
cancers, non-melanoma skin cancers, and history of two or
more second malignancies. This work has been extended into
understanding specific genetic factors such as impact
on DNA repair mechanisms,
genes affecting DNA repair mechanisms, or combinations
of
polygenic risk scores that may affect specific outcomes, not only
related to second cancers, but also other outcomes like
cardiometabolic conditions. And this may help us in the future
really pursue more of a precision focused survivorship
care.
Now, another important outcome that's been alluded to in our previous speakers is
aging in our survivors, and with the
availability of standardized performance assessments in the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort, Dr. Cary Ness at St.
Jude has led seminal studies looking at frailty in this phenotype that we
are seeing in our survivors. Which we know with frailty, it's a loss of
physiologic capacity that interferes with normal function, that all of us will
experience at some point in our lifetime, and it has been associated with
morbidity and mortality in aging populations.
We also appreciate that disease, the cancer, chemotherapy,
radiation surgeries, and other interventions really change to an
earlier onset of presentation of frailty in our pediatric
cancer survivors. And these, typically one is assessing
the specific components of fitness, muscle wasting,
muscle weakness, self-reported exhaustion, slow walking
speed, low energy expenditure, with frail
including three or more of these components and pre frail, two of these
components, and this is standard according to three criteria used in the general
population.
And so what Dr. Ness and her group determined
using these same criteria and comparing outcomes in the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort, here our cohort is aged 18 to 50,
a mean of about 34 years, noted in red,
to that of the cardiovascular health outcome study participants who are
aged 65 to 101 years, in blue,
in our control population, the St. Jude Lifetime Cohort.
So you can see that frailty
prevalence was comparable. Pre-frail was in excess
in our much, much younger survivors.
And in determining the outcomes of individuals who are frail versus
not frail, there was actually a 2.6 hazard ratio
for early death within the frail population, and
compared to adjusted hazard ratio in the cardiovascular health study of
2.24. So this can be quite impactful on our survivors and really
has informed interventions by Dr.
Ness and her team to promote performance,
support
preservation of lean muscle mass, and other interventions to help with
healthy aging.
Now, other investigators have looked at what are the mechanisms and the
pathways underpinning this frail
phenotype. Beyond disease burden and frailty as described
by Dr. Ness,
our group has looked at telomere length, epigenetic alteration, mitochondrial
dysfunction, and genomic instability.
And I'll show one set of examples of those studies, and this is led by Dr.
Wong and his group. He looked at epigenetic age and noted that it was
highly correlated with chronologic age in our survivors, noted in
the gold line.
And the survivors had an annualannual higher change of
epigenetic age compared to controls, and there were
significant associations that were independent after multivariable
modeling with age acceleration related to specific diagnostic
groups. Overall, survivors were higher, but you can see specific
diagnostic groups, particularly Hodgkin lymphoma survivors, which
anecdotally really appeared to be quite impacted, even as we're risk adapting
therapies. And then you can see similar trends for higher
epigenetic age acceleration associated with specific treatments,
chest radiation, abdominal pelvic radiation, alkylating agent, et
cetera. And these studies have actually also been extended
to
show significant associations with health behaviors, diet,
as well as specific chronic health conditions.
Now we have opportunities to mitigate risk, and this example
focuses, and the speaker focuses on what might one do with
cardiomyopathy risk. We know that survivors for a specific outcome like
cardiomyopathy may have a baseline risk.
We know that they may have baseline or genetic familial
factors that may make them more vulnerable.
We may prescribe to them, in the course of their cancer experience,
specific agents that may put them at higher risk at an earlier
onset, or they may have other cardiac comorbidities that may
put them at a higher risk. But we have the opportunity here
to right shift this curve and preserve health as our survivors are aging
by interventions that focus on physical activity,
pharmacologic interventions, healthy diet, and then aggressive management of
comorbidities. So this is our focus in understanding what are the layers of
risk and how we can change the trajectory to help our
survivors with healthy aging.
Now, optimizing these outcomes after childhood cancer, we consider
cancer specific effects, disease specific effects, chronic
disease burden, aging, health behaviors, and
psychosocial factors affecting access and
adherence. And really, as we look at the many aspects of
rehabilitation services, we've appreciated, particularly at an institution like
St. Jude, where there is a holistic approach to care in the
pediatric age group, our survivors as they enter community care, which
most will do across the globe at some point in
their cancer experience, their access to this type of service to help
with healthy aging becomes pretty limited.
And so I want to share one, I think, very important
study that we did looking at financial hardship after childhood cancer.
These outcomes were assessed in 2,800 survivors in our cohort
who were a mean of 32 years and beyond
20 years from their cancer diagnosis. And in this study, Dr.
Wang led a group that looked at financial situation, healthcare
affordability, healthcare access,
life insurance access, retirement planning, physical and emotional
symptoms, and health related quality of life.
And the results showed that financial hardship was prevalent among our
survivors, with about a third reporting impact in one
domain and two thirds reporting impact in
two,
and the specific domains that were affected were material hardship and
impact of cancer on financial situation in
22.4%, psychological hardship with
concern about ability to pay for care and medical expenses
in 51%, and behavioral hardship,
inability to see a doctor or go to the hospital because of finances
in 33%. So I used to think, "Oh, we provide all
this care for children and this experience is over." This family
is impacted forever with this cancer experience.
It then is a legacy to the survivor, particularly if they require
resources beyond the pediatric cancer center to
maintain their health as they're aging.
It's also important to note that the consequences of financial hardship can be
substantial on quality of life. In this study, hardship was associated
with somatization, anxiety, depression, and
suicidal ideation across all measures of
assessment, material, psychological, and behavioral.
So the clinical implications of this is that it's really important to assess
financial hardship in our survivors who are reporting emotional distress,
assess emotional stress in those who are reporting
financial concerns, and then facilitate referrals to
psychological services and intervention.
So in supporting our childhood cancer survivors, which most of you probably are
focused on adult onset cancer, but in pediatric
practices, we focus in particular on those outcomes that affect
growth and development.
We are evaluating educational progress and psychosocial functioning,
prioritizing those late effects, and doing the types of screening based on
their treatment and their age at exposure that will affect their risk
of
intellectual disabilities and growth failure, et cetera, facilitating
referrals to the appropriate services and reminding their caregivers
about cancer diagnosis and risks related to treatment in an effort to
really educate them to promote healthy behaviors within their family.
In our adolescents and young adults, we similarly assess educational
progress and vocational goals and psychosocial functioning and make the
same referrals. We begin to educate them directly as
developmentally appropriate about their cancer diagnosis and risk and
support their efforts in adherence to chronic disease management, as
many are already collecting comorbidities before they graduate from pediatric
cancer programs. It's important that they know their role in promoting
healthy behaviors, and this extends to vaccination, substance
abuse, and sexual practices.
We counsel them about the impact of cancer and treatment on family building and
pregnancy risk. Ideally, this is done before initiation
of therapy and survivorship. It's important to continue these
discussions as developmentally appropriate and support those
survivors with appropriate referrals.
And as our survivors are leaving us in pediatric care,
we introduce a need for adult focused surveillance, and this may be on subsequent
cancers, and we also introduce a concept of accelerated aging
associated with cancer treatment so we can help them advocate in
their interactions with their community healthcare
providers about their unique vulnerabilities related to their pediatric cancer
experience.Supporting the transitions from oncology care
is critical.
As we know, our survivors now,
in excess of half a million in the United States, will move on to
community care. It's important that young adults are aware of their cancer
treatment risk and screening, they understand their role in risk mitigation
related to health behaviors, and adherence to risk-based screening to facilitate
early detection. We need to support their access to services and
resources that address these challenges.
This may take a lot of navigation with social work and creativity
based on the specific built environment where these survivors are living,
working, and playing.
We develop survivorship care plans for all of the survivors in our practice
and try to educate them about the importance of using this
tool to interact with local providers to ensure they get access
to care. And we also engage them in understanding their
contribution to late outcomes research actually can benefit
the next generation of survivors by helping us
develop safer therapies, understanding how to monitor them long term,
and help guide their care for the future.
So I'd like to end by acknowledging
our funding resources, as I presented largely studies from the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort.
It's a huge contribution to the survivors who are in this study.
They come every five years, for essentially a campus
evaluation that's now standardly applied across organ systems
that take about the greater part of a week to accomplish.
And so we thank them for their time that they spent, and I thank you for your
attention.
So questions, again, please come to the microphone, but you'll probably have to
yell because we can't hear you. As people are coming up, I actually have a
question, and this isn't meant to be exclusionary, but this increase in
frailty that you see, do you think it's mechanistically
different than a full-grown adult?
Do you think there's something with development here, or is it just because their
runway has been so much longer that it's-
We actually don't know, but that's interesting because in our
recently funded new U01 for the St.
Jude Lifetime Cohort, Dr. Ness is actually going to be looking
at, and Dr. Kroll, a neuropsychologist that worked with us, they are looking at
specific outcomes related to neuromuscular and neurocognitive function
within the survivor cohort that will help us understand
mechanistically, are we seeing the impact on lean muscle
mass and some of the other performance parameters or cognitive parameters,
is there a different mechanism that's underpinning that that may be informative for
interventions?
Any other questions?
All right. I want to, again, thank all of you for starting the first session off
with a boom. Enjoy the rest of the meeting, and
have a good day